[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mark sanchez former usc quarterback of
course uh nfl quarterback with the jets
he stopped by yesterday we had a chance
to sit down with him and the first thing
i asked mark was if you're walking
around in los angeles what do people say
to you
it's funny it's hit or miss sometimes i
get matt liner
sometimes i get uh adrian grenier from
uh oh entourage vinnie chase yep okay um
that's usually it okay what do you mean
lopez
what do you say when somebody says hey
matt liner
well
this is funny i went to this uh
business conference
and this guy comes and gives me a huge
hug i don't know
it says man
that apartment complex i mean i told you
it's blown up
and i'm like what you're talking about
it's like you know we went out on the
apartment complex it's doing so well
they got seven more i mean i'm making
bank on that thing you're in it too
and i'm like
dude what are you talking about and he
finally goes come on man don't mess with
heisman guy now heisman now you're too
big time like
i'm like dude i didn't win a heisman
he's like matt and i said mark and he
goes
[Laughter]
oh my god i'm so sorry
just totally missed uh good morning i
was convicted good
oh not a convicted felon no he was just
convicted
convicted okay um good month for usc
football wouldn't you say i think we're
winning the off-season
[Music]
whatever
news media battle but that's for sure
and transfer portal what good what does
lincoln riley's style mean um
you know i think
most importantly it it seems like things
are shifting the way it was
when i was coming out of high school and
that was carson palmer mattliner
that was the only place to go right like
if you're a socal quarterback
you look nowhere else it was norm chow
it was steve sarkeesian it was pete
carroll that's where you wanted to be
and for a long time now i mean look at
all the guys in the sec georgia took um
uh the kid from modern day uh jtj
daniels um the kid from clemson who
angela lay is uh is from bosco right
orange county l.a and then uh bryce
young's modern day and these guys are
across the country how did they get out
of southern california that's the
problem is
it wasn't a desirable place to go and
why is wasn't a quarterback factory
anymore but now it's kyler it's uh baker
mayfield it's um
uh jalen hurts
where else are you gonna go if you're a
quarterback that's the guy so
hopefully that brings people back and
reminds them that they don't have to
leave because if we just keep california
even just if he cut california in half
and took the southern part
i mean we're competitive now but all
these guys are leaving
who was runner-up for you coming out of
high school
runner-up what do you mean
oh next school yeah um geez
i went to texas ohio state notre dame
i looked at ucla briefly
but um
yeah mac brown mac brown was great he
was hard to say no to but jim tressel i
remember we were in the horseshoe they
had the band
i had a ohio state jersey they put my
highlight tape up on the mega tron or
whatever
they audio dubbed keith jackson's voice
over it and it was supposed to be like
the rose bowl and then they were showing
my high school highlights on this thing
and i was like i'm a buckeye
done deal i hear keith jackson the young
sophomore from southern california you
know
and i was like wow and we're in
trestle's office and i'm like this is it
like i'm about to sign a paper and i'm
going to be a buckeye
and then he said
you know it's it's awesome uh every year
we play michigan right around
thanksgiving
10 years in a row great football weather
it's been snowing every game
and i was like what
i looked at my dad i was like what did
he say
i was like snow we gotta drive to big
bear for snow
mammoth yeah i was like i'm out
so
it was pretty funny that kind of that
really just changed my mind right there
wait did you do any research on what
weather's like in columbus
it's silly now looking back i'm like
what a [ __ ]
but i don't you look at the jerseys you
look at the coaches you look at okay
what am i going to do here um you know
it's a good education great i didn't
think twice about the weather
no clue name image and likeness and
where it's going because
caleb williams is really the first true
free agent we've probably seen i'm
curious what he got from usc yeah um
because everything's legal now right i
mean i just feel like here
in l.a
you have so much to offer these kids
um you know you can go speak at a
boosters golf tournament now 10 grand
bam
like
you could get
maybe 20 grand so you're doing five
quick little talks playing a golf
tournament
there's a hundred grand right there i
mean go sign some autographs at a
dealership like
it's so easy but how did the sec master
this i mean young reportedly got 1.3
million from alabama
and those are just guaranteed deals i'm
sure like he was making more than jalen
hurts was as an nfl quarterback last
year mark i believe it i just saw that
sound bite of um
jimbo fisher
yes clown actually yeah yeah
he wants everybody to think i'm a great
recruiter and we would never pay for
anybody
i mean come on come on they got they got
oil money down there mark
it's
it's legal now yeah you know like just
just let it go like it's on
because now you just sort of say all
right what do you got for me exactly and
the parents you know this transfer
portal thing is
interesting too because i feel like the
parents even when i was coming out like
parents like to be recruited you know
they want to know how good johnny is you
know
and now these kids like
play a little bit their first year boom
and they're in the portal just to go on
trips again just to go visit and okay
what do you have for me well they said
they got 30. you only have 20 you know
it's um it's unbelievable but it's legal
i uh i saw kenny pickett went to the
senior bowl and of course he's got small
hands mark
so
thoughts and prayers for uh kenny
pickett sure but then you hear he's the
most ready quarterback and how important
you got big hands i have massive hands
yes so
obviously you have to have massive hands
to play in the nfl i mean i think it's a
huge advantage um
you know a slick ball when it's wet in
the elements it helps um
favre
really big hands and his thumb it was
like his thumb on his throwing hand that
was like extra long it was really weird
but i played golf with him one time and
i kind of looked at it like huh
must have been it yes he got some extra
juice on the ball but
it's
it's something it's not everything but
um it definitely helps but when you went
to the combine like what stood out that
you you realized boy that this means a
little bit more than it should yeah i
remember
you go uh so if you have an injury i had
dislocated my patella on my left leg
whatever injury you have
they look at and 32 team doctors
will go and
crank on it
and by the end of that day
this thing was a basketball
because i had heard it my senior year at
sc
so i'm like dude i got to run a 40
tomorrow there's no way i got to drop
back and throw i mean we were icing that
thing massaging that thing like crazy
because they were just pulling on it
pulling on it pushing on it prodding it
how does this feel how does this extend
you know all this stuff
i'm like oh my god you're like a lab rat
and
it was awful i mean it was still so
swollen when i was running and
everything it sucks that was the worst
part paula you got uh mark's measurables
of course i do uh mark sanchez coming
out of usc measure 10.5 inches on your
hand size which is tied for 10th all
time in combine history congratulations
thank you
i was growing them out for the combine
[Laughter]
what uh you got his 40 there uh 488 i
got 488 yeah
okay
where's that rank with other usc
quarterbacks carson was faster than that
carson's definitely faster than that
liner that had to be faster than lining
it
if it wasn't i'm gonna be pissed matt
barkley
ah
gotta be
i don't know yeah paulie
yeah 4.9 seconds for matt leinart
yes you owned him two-tenths you owned
him take that uh mark is joining us on
behalf of uh papa john celebrating its
uh new york style pizza fans unique
pizza rituals and a special giveaway
i'll let you uh take the sales pitch
from there yeah let's go so basically
super bowl sunday number one day to
order pizza
they just introduced this new york style
pizza uh you know 13 bucks eight huge
slices fold it in half dip it in the
garlic sauce there's nothing better so
basically what they want you to do is
for a chance to win pizza free pizza for
an entire year you can upload your
pictures of you eating this new york
style pizza on instagram twitter and
hashtag sweepstakes hashtag what's your
style
and they will pick a winner and
obviously you brought in some pizza for
us let's go oh here's where's the
hello there's no you didn't bring any
you know who would have brought pizza
matt liner oh it would have been slow
[Laughter]
um
if i gave you joe burrow or matthew
stafford for this game
i hate betting against joe burrow i love
that kid man i sat down with him right
before
he has this incredible ascension at lsu
obviously i'm not taking credit for it
but i went to go visit
uh eddio
[Laughter]
and uh seton does uh ed it's great
let's hear a little coach
well dan i was just saying
i
thought you were doing papa john's
um so answer it if you were coach oh
talking about joe burrow well joe
number one go tigers
and joe he got the eye of the tiger
he got a heart like a lion
and you love him some gumbo
listen
i love joe i think he's so impressive
especially nine sacks in that divisional
game are you kidding me and that dude
didn't even flinch most quarterbacks
your eyes just start dropping okay i'm
i'm guilty of it tom brady's guilty of
it you name it you get hit that many
times
you stop looking downfield and you're
like damn i gotta find a throwing lane
because i'm gonna get my head taken off
he didn't flinch so i love him i'd love
to see him do well i just think he's
gonna get another crack at it and
stafford and i came in the same year
i just really want it i want it for him
i really want him to win it he's been
through so much in detroit
and it finally worked out you know
everybody said well if he was with
another coordinator if he had a
supporting cast well now he does so
i'd love to see him win did you ever get
too cocky beating brady did you ever
feel like no way
no way it was um
it's it's so funny because when you
you look at people like that him you
know kobe jordan like those kind of
people
players talk about playing those guys
and they know they got to be perfect and
you're hoping he screws up once you know
you're hoping we get a interception on a
screen pass by david harris who got
caught by algae crumpler by the way what
he should have taken that in for a
touchdown i think we miss a field goal
on that or we did something but i i
missed a throw but basically it was
crappy but
um
you just know everything's got to line
up and you got to hope for for a bad one
from him and
that was so impressive to me that
sustained
greatness that sustained success it's
it's incredible
did you beat him
what do you mean
how many times did you beat him oh uh
well we beat him at home
my rookie year my second year
and then we beat him in the playoffs so
like the first but you're not stupid
you're starting to feel yourself like
you know and i all right
i just you know what i didn't realize
i didn't realize like i knew what it was
but i really didn't
now looking back
you're like damn that was just the first
part of his three hall of fame career
you know like part one that was just
part one
and
i i didn't realize it because we beat
him at home the first time
um
so it didn't register it was just you
know there's a big rivalry and everybody
was talking about it but we beat him so
i was like whatever
um
i don't know it was it was really
strange those first couple years and
then
after the first two or three i mean we
just got smoked
it was rough
it was rough uh it's great to see you
again thank you uh thanks for coming out
appreciate it mark sanchez who didn't
bring pizza yeah
yeah
no pizza no pizza
so we taped that and then mark felt so
bad mark then sent some pizzas here to
the to the crew
yeah it was like and then fritzy goes he
only sent two pizzas i don't want to
look a gift trojan horse in the mallow
there's a whole staff of people what is
two pizzas gonna do i could eat that by
myself in the background well no he was
sending the pizza for us four
so two for four people i still think you
gotta go within three uh he hasn't seen
me sit down in front of a table full of
people i know fritzy goes you know that
that's a minimum four pizza like yeah
you've got to send four pizzas
make sure there's a whole story i know i
don't i know i know i know who eats
pizza besides me at ten o'clock in the
morning that's another thing that's
weird
but it's actually
our body clock would be one o'clock in
the afternoon east coast time i would
have preferred him to send a couple
pizzas to my hotel room and forget about
you we had bloody mary's yesterday at uh
9 9 20 in the morning man that was one
of the best bloody marys i ever had
we went to a place right across the
street from our hotel
and i'm with um ariel and the french kid
and uh seton and seton goes i could do a
bloody mary
all right i'll go bloody mary and then
uh you know french kid in ariel got
beers we had breakfast tacos and i
thought all right that's such a a great
nap yes it will yes it will especially
the second bloody mary that i had i went
back and i'm like i am gone so